after the March the fight
once again Hong Kong's air is thick with
tear gas
police versus protester angry and
determined this is now a familiar game
of cat and mouse we will keep fighting
what those we may we make don't get out
today but everywhere else maybe everyday
everywhere will come out March and fight
for what we want just the democracy and
freedom and our human right wave after
wave the tear gas and pepper spray came
in choking and blinding protesters and
press
but almost two months of demonstrations
have hardened this resistance and
strengthened their resolve and there are
still thousands on the streets there
shouting liberate Hong Kong they're
calling for revolution a battle against
an extradition bill has now become a
fight for full democracy freedom from a
Beijing backed government the action
started earlier when groups barricaded
roads this driver was attacked when he
tried to push back four others who were
trapped it was a worrying change in tone
I think today is a bit of a landmark
I've been here 40 years this is the
first time it's touched me in admiralty
focus I don't know why they're in
central right now they're not even
central this is a highway to park Fulham
you know it's Sunday night what's going
on why is this van being smashed I have
no idea what's going through your mind
when you see this stay calm keep my kids
in the car calm you know Hong Kong is an
amazing place these people have just the
most amazing right to fight for Hong
Kong so I I'm behind them but at the
same time I want to get my kids home but
hundreds of thousands in this city are
still choosing peaceful protests I know
a hunger striker urges the crowds to
keep going this is angel and her
toddlers 5th March with a small child I
think this is so at least something that
I can do
and the more the government wants to
want us to give up does it drag on or
the policy and everything and the
responses the more I think we need to
stand firm the clashes and confrontation
that started about a bill have now
evolved they will not back down they
cannot stop because they believe this is
the last chance to save Hong Kong
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Hong Kong